Je suis un défenseur des droits de l'homme qui a fondé
Madonna qui est maintenant une grande équipe
d'enfants soldats qui se passe depuis
le début de la guerre ce n'est pas la
première fois en 2000 seulement en 2018 nous avons
documenté plus de 1000 citoyens et
la plupart des incidents pour les enfants soldats
ou l'utilisation à des fins militaires s'est produite par
Hafiz et d'autres et s'est également produite par les
forces mandataires émiraties et les groupes fidèles au
gouvernement Heidi et la nouveauté en
2018 dans les cas de filles qui ont été
recrutées par ses champs à des fins militaires
Je suis responsable de plus  plus de 70 et d'
autres groupes sont également responsables du
recrutement d'enfants et d'autres niveaux,
c'est un domaine très compliqué et nous avons
rempli des chercheurs partout au Yémen dans 20
gouvernorats,
donc bien que ceux qui notre structure de filtre
documentent quotidiennement les incidents et
nous dans l'eau maintenant quand nous disons que nous  documenter
cet incident, cela signifie que nous avons visité
le côté, nous avons des entretiens avec des
témoins oculaires survivants des travailleurs du secteur de la santé
et pour nous assurer que les
informations sont exactes, beaucoup de membres de notre équipe,
dont moi, ont été détenus et à
différentes périodes au Yémen, il y a une
énorme campagne contre Madonna  de toutes
les parties au conflit et ce n'est pas
facile d'être un indépendant en G ou parmi
des groupes armés et votre voisin une
Arabie Saoudite mais jusqu'à présent nous
nous protégeons en étant indépendants neutres
et professionnels pour faire tout ce que nous voulons que cette
guerre s'arrête mais bien plus  que cela, nous
voulons que les civils soient protégés dans tous les
cas et la responsabilité et la justice sont
l'un de nos objectifs, nous construisons une
mémoire des droits de l'homme qui non seulement pour protéger
les civils maintenant, mais aussi pour
la responsabilité et la justice à l'avenir,
je vois que c'est très possible c'est  ce qui est
vraiment triste au Yémen cette pièce est très
possible et n'arrive jamais parce que
personne ne s'en soucie parce qu'il y a un gros
intérêt financier qui est plus
important que l'innocent innocent le
sang d'innocents
oui le commerce des armes est un mot clé dans la guerre
au Yémen parce que  nous avons découvert
à travers notre travail que le Yémen n'est
pas oublié et qu'il est ignoré et que le
commerce des armes fait partie de ce Royaume-Uni en France
et aux États-Unis.  nos sociétés alliées et les
lamantins et ils ne font aucune pression
pour protéger les civils ou pour résoudre le
problème au Yémen cela signifie-t-il que les autres
parties au conflit ne commettent pas
de violations de la narcose mais ils
s'encouragent tous à faire plus de
violations avec  un énorme manque de
responsabilité
vous